saleh youtubers e benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione
come sapete i generi che prediligo di
più recensire sono lection el'horror da
quattro soldi
quindi ho pensato di dare una ventata di
aria fresca recen se non family movie o
come piace chiamarlo a me quelli che
trovi la domenica pomeriggio in tv
mentre il tuo pc dal tecnico perché tuo
padre a per sbaglio installato nei virus
sono andato a ripescare una pellicola
del 1988 chiamata mccamey ve lo dico
subito e la copia sputata mal prodotta a
fatta solo per fare soldi dt non mi
credete guardate la locandina ricorda
qualcosa
non ci hanno neanche provato a fare
qualcosa di diverso non ci hanno neanche
provato è come se fosse stato fatto
apposta per essere insultato quindi
diamo un'occhiata approfondita a me che
mi il film inizia con questo è il male
fatto ad alieno sembrano la fusione tra
gollum del signore degli anelli gobbi di
harry potter e andreotti quali persona
sana di mente creerebbe delle creature
del no lui non cota mio di non riesco
neanche a guardarli per più di cinque
secondi di fila mi fanno impressione
comunque mentre il più grande è intento
a bere da una roccia con una cannuccia
vedono atterrare una somma americana
intenta a raccogliere campioni di
terreno
[Musica]
vengono per sbaglio risucchiati da un
tubo all'interno della sonda
[Musica]
giuro ogni scena che commento sembra
essere uscita fuori da un film porno ed
ora lascia di bere l'acqua dalle narici
con una cannuccia mentre td soffio da un
tubo all'interno della vab e avete
capito
fatto sta che la sonda ritorna sulla
terra e in un laboratorio segreto e gli
alieni riescono a fuggire
[Musica]
ok se il film si degnasse di farmi
vedere per due secondi una scena che
riesco a capire sarebbe un passo avanti
hanno fatto esplodere la saracinesca
soltanto toccandola
[Musica]
hai visto cosa mi è costretto a fare
film né costretto ad usare una battuta
vecchia di anni e siamo solo a 10 minuti
padre madre fratello scappano da una
parte mac il più piccolo si ritrova
invece da solo
buongiorno palesi controfigure che
indossa un costume quando poco prima era
solo un pupazzo complimenti
noi divertente perfetto sia anche visto
il filo che non teneva legato ottimo
lavoro
[Musica]
io non sto ridendo e dovrei perché
questa è la classica scena di comicità
fisica che questo genere di film hanno
mai fatta talmente realistica e non è
divertente da anzi è angosciante
credo che qualcuno sia morto da qualche
parte e poi grazie non avevo proprio
bisogno di dormire stanotte
mentre i genitori si ritrovano sperduti
nel deserto anche se la base era in una
zona completamente diversa mac si
nasconde nell'auto di una famiglia che
si sta per trasferire in una nuova casa
ha tra l'altro a quanto pare ha il
potere di allungarsi scopriamo che eric
il figlio più piccolo è costretto in
sedia a rotelle e nessuno lo vede che mi
fermo in piedi
certo ovvio normalissimo si sta
nascondendo così bene
[Musica]
a parte il fatto di scoprire che mac può
attivare gli oggetti elettronici
soltanto toccandoli e vuol dire potere
utilissimo nel loro pianeta dove non c'è
uno schifo di nulla da nessuna parte
ma a parte quello io in questa scena
vedo solo scritto ho scritto scritto
scritto scritto scritto compra compra
sopra scritto si compra compra compra
scritto compra compra compra skittles
non hanno neanche provato a nascondere
la busta un minimo no in primo piano
messa a fuoco
comprate la nostra roba mentre max k
eric lo insegue in cortile dalla casa di
fianco appare la vicina ad ebi che è
riuscita a vedere lo sgorbio no ho detto
di no carino carino quella creatura
infernale che sembra uno dei muppets
dopo essere stato colpito da dosi
massicce di radiazioni è carino
signorina si faccia operare il pool b
oculari e che e si parte con una delle
cose che maggiormente ho odiato
crescendo con i film degli anni 90 il
fattore giuro che esiste in tutti quei
film in cui c'è una creatura o un
animale in possesso di un ragazzo tra i
10 e 15 anni poi giocarci testicoli che
tutta la prima metà sarà piena di
momenti tipo non sono stato io a rompere
il vaso è stata la creatura misteriosa
certo come no va in camera tua io le
odiavo non potevo guardarmi mezzo film
con cani sciglio pappagalli perché mi
davano sui nervi queste cose
giuro mamma mary a vedere ma cui non c'è
nulla giuro che prima c'era mi hai
mentito se in punizione ma mamma
punizione fotte di mamma fotte idee
volete una prova
diamo un'occhiata a questa scena durante
la notte mac combina un casino fa
crescere erbe piante in tutto il salotto
distruggendolo e tra l'altro siamo a tre
poteri e la madre colpo
di scena dalla colpa voi ed il ten
ma porca eva prima di tutto come puoi
pensare che un ragazzino in una notte
riesca a fare tutto questo casino
secondo non so se te ne sei accorta
durante tutto il periodo in cui la è
cresciuto è in sedia a rotelle
spiegami come avrebbe potuto mettere
quelli più attesi rincoglionita ma
aspettate perché a quanto pare non è
l'unica ad essersene dimenticata anche
eric stesso se ne dimentica
mentre cerca mac nel cortile di casa si
trova sul bordo di un lupo eric ti
spiego la cosa
l'accelerazione con cui un corpo
discende un piano inclinato e
proporzionale al seno dell'angolo di
inclinazione
[Musica]
esatto idiota
prima di commentare questa splendida
splendida scena vi dico una cosa
l'attore che interpreta aerei che si
chiama jidka lavori ed è realmente
affetto da un problema che lo ha
costretto in sedia a rotelle quindi devo
andarci piano con le battute a queste
scene fantastica
a partire da eric stesso sostituito da
un manichino l'urlo che hanno dovuto
difendere tre volte per farlo sembrare
più lungo e mac che per tirarsi su lo
hanno dovuto fare in digitale wow
l'apoteosi del trash in dieci secondi
splendido comunque mac si tuffa in acqua
e lo salva ovviamente non possono far
morire il protagonista di un film per
ragazzi
o forse sì
[Musica]
sarebbe stato abbastanza disturbante
però bellissimo la sera eric ed ebbe
decidono di catturarlo con
l'aspirapolvere che per quanto sia
un'idea delle balle credo funzionerà
[Musica]
maman che riesce a fare casini anche
dalla dentro
[Musica]
[Applauso]
lo sai cosa ha fatto quella braccia
gaffe di tua figlia
[Musica]
finalmente anche il fratello grande
riesce a vederlo ma è ferito gravemente
per farlo riprendere gli fanno bene
della coca coca coca coca coca compra
coca compra compra compra coca copre
qualche qualche candela compra coca cola
e di nuovo la madre non gli crede sono
scioccato intanto i parenti sono ancora
persi nel deserto e cercano di mandare
un segnale fischiato al figlio
[Musica]
ora arriva l'unico momento che mi ha
sinceramente divertito mentre eric va a
correre con la madre nova corre nel
senso che va a fare quei passi ma fatemi
spiega eric accompagna la madre a fare
jogging e nel frattempo mecca ruba
un'automobilina elettrica e viene
inseguito da una mandria di cani
schiantandosi contro un albero per conto
sul real e devo dire che mi ha fatto
ridere ma ovviamente hanno dovuto
rovinarla con questo
[Musica]
d
cento
[Musica]
a forlì
questa musica perché sembra che da un
momento all'altro debba partire una
scena tipo lui che guarda l'orizzonte
pensa a quanto gli manchino i genitori
mano si inquadra soltanto loro che
corrono ai cani sotto l'albero fide
oggi
[Musica]
prima lezione di regia ragazzi le scene
devono avere un senso
nel frattempo gli uomini in meno del
laboratorio cercano da tutte le parti il
povero mac degeneres a rete di destro
sia come come avevo capire che michael
ha scosso da loro da quei diavoli
sherlock holmes sei tu ad alimentare mio
caro watson
eri deve andare ad una festa di
compleanno con debbie ma non può
lasciare mac da solo quindi sentite la
genialata lo traveste da orsacchiotto
che tutti hanno un orsacchiotto con gli
occhi sbarrati come se fosse in un trip
di acidi sì è vero hai anche tu gli
occhi sbarella team aiutiamo comunque
esatto e dopo skittles e coca cola
a quale altra multinazionale possiamo
fare pubblicità in modo subdolo e
discreto davvero film davvero cielo
sbatti in faccia così brutalmente senza
neanche chiederci di uscire prima
ma se pensate che questo sia il peggio
date un'occhiata a questa merda
[Musica]
ok diretta sia l'hanno fatto sono
riusciti a mettere una gigantesca
pubblicità del mcdonald all'interno del
film ma l'avrei accettata l'avrei
accettata di più se avesse avuto un
senso con la trama ma no era chiedere
troppo
vediamo invece una scena di ballo
completamente a culo nel mezzo del film
siete senza vergogna no non lo accetto
vieni qui fin qui destra faccio vedere
io
se voi devono è capito sei vomitevole
non meriti di fare con le altre scene
sapete chi mi viene in mente guardando
questa roba comunque me che eric
scappano in mezzo alla strada
anche qui dovrebbe essere divertente mai
tutto mette i brividi
era un pelo non viene investito da
un'auto dopo essere stati salvati dal
fratello e dalla madre si mettono in
viaggio per cercare i parenti di mac
[Musica]
ti prego muoviti ancora più lentamente
perché non sono riuscito a leggere la
marca li trovano dentro una grotta in
fin di vita e li curano facendogli bere
coca cola
li caricano in macchina e decidono il da
farsi come finirà la storia di erika e
della famiglia di creature così
ripugnanti che neanche mistero
riuscirebbe ad inventarle questo finale
questo finale è atroce così stupido così
strano così il fratello di eric decide
di portare gli alieni in un centro con
oblò scusate mi serve un secondo il
tempo prima di raccontarvelo decide di
portare gli alieni in un cie in un
centro commerciale davvero davvero hai
per caso cervello completamente [__]
come pensi che finirà
qualche rivelazione inaspettata solo
degli allievi inguardabili come pensi
che avrebbero reagito
poi una cosa magari sono io ad essere
puntiglioso è ma per degli alieni che
hanno la capacità di attivare i congegni
elettronici toccandoli di allungarsi e
di far crescere le piante
veramente non concepisce che se prendi
una lattina dal fondo fa il cadere tutte
quelle sopra è forse sono io a chiedere
troppo vengono circondati dai poliziotti
e per sbaglio parte una sparatoria
[Musica]
sì più grande quella esplosione facevano
il 3x2 sulle bombe atomiche nel negozio
gesù è link che si trovava troppo vicino
all'esplosione
non ci crederete mai muore
[Musica]
no non finisce nemmeno così sarebbe
stato fantastico però scopriamo che gli
alieni sono ancora tv come quando perché
può e che oltre agli altri poteri
possono riportare le persone in vita
[Musica]
[Applauso]
in più ecco spiegato tutto solo delle
divinità sono i supereroi del nuovo
millennio sono onnipotenti ogni scempi
certo poi non sanno che se prendi la
lattina da sotto cade tutto quello sopra
ma solo di vini e allora dopo tutto
questo casino ti chiedi ma come finirà
il film come di non proprio siccome la
gente capisce che non fanno del male ad
una mosca
li fanno diventare cittadini americani o
gioia ma guarda qui che orrore sono
terrificanti vestiti così e vissero
tutti felici e contenti
[Musica]
quindi questo era il fastidiosissimo me
che mi ha scelto questo per farvi capire
che i film brutti non sono solo quelli
con effetti speciali da quattro soldi o
con la recitazione scadente ma anche
quelli dove tutto il resto sembra andare
quasi bene ma l'intera sceneggiatura esm
inziata un film che ha semplicemente
voluto capitalizzare con il successo di
un film più famoso
io vi ringrazio per aver visto il video
e ci vediamo ad una prossima recensione